I think jewelry is the most
magical thing you can wear
For something so small that can fit
in the palm of your hand,
it can hold a world of
memories and emotions.
It has the ability to reach into the past
as well as reach into the future,
and I find that endearingly romantic.
A lot of jewelry embodies
a lot of human suffering,
whether that is the suffering of miners,
whether it's the environmental disruption,
they produce something very beautiful,
but it often comes at
a kind of nasty cost.
The more people get concerned about that,
the more they are open to alternatives.
In this place, we mine the
sky to get the gases we need
to make diamonds.
Our entire ingredient
list is the wind, the sun,
the rain and atmospheric
carbon, that's it, no more.
There is still so much to explore
in the world of science and
also material innovation
and how to turn something
negative and wasteful
into the things that we want.
Anabela Chan is telling a new
21st century romantic story
about jewelry, which is
that the designer's eye
is just as important as the
materials they're made from.
I've made pieces for everyone
from sort of Beyonce,
to Rihanna, to Taylor Swift,
Julia Roberts, Lupita Nyong'o.
From the Oscars to the Grammys.
When I told people I wanted to create fine
and high jewelry using
laboratory grown gemstones,
people thought I was crazy .
There are several pieces
from my own collection
that I treasure.
One of them is this ring
from the late Andrew Grima.
This was one of his sort of
architectural inspired rings
that he designed in the '70s.
He is known as the father of
contemporary jewelry design.
He famously said that a 50 carat Topaz
can become a work of art
that can be worn and enjoyed,
yet a 60 sort of carat
diamond needs to be locked up
in a vault.
Traditionally, high fine jewelry
is notoriously exclusive.
I wanted it to be more accessible,
because it is the ultimate craftsmanship.
It's the ultimate sort
of handcrafted treasure
that shouldn't just be accessible
by so few people in the world.
The most beautiful colors
and geometries and textures
come from nature.
And a lot of the times when I design
I'm merely trying to
capture that moment of magic
I see in nature, transforming
that into something
that can be worn.
I would always start
by having a sketchbook
and my drawing easel,
and going to draw
subjects that interest me.
Just seeing something ordinary
as something extraordinary.
The two pieces we're making
are a pair of broaches
inspired by a blade of
grass with morning dew drops
sort of running through the veins.
I will then start to sketch
each piece of jewelry in pencil.
And then from those initial sketches,
there could be hundreds of them,
I will then take sort of my favorite ones,
and then transition them into paints
which is known as jewelry renderings.
That will essentially be
like a map for the craftsmen
to work with.
I was trained very
traditionally at art college
as a fine jewelry designer,
working with sort of mined gemstones,
and I think what really sort
of changed my trajectory
was when I went on my
honeymoon to Sri Lanka.
I knew that Sri Lanka was
famous for its color stones,
and so I made a few visits to
artisanal mines in the area.
These are some of of the
most precious commodities
in the world and yet the
people who mine these stones
live some of the harshest
conditions in the world,
it just didn't make any sense.
And that's when I began my research
into laboratory grown gemstones,
gemstones cultivated in a science lab
rather than mined from the ground.
So I'm sat here in the
Cotswolds, in our lab,
the place where we created the process
to make these diamonds from the sky.
The most permanent form of carbon
that we know of is a diamond.
We set out to do this in
order to lock carbon up
into a permanent form.
It's like a carbon capture
and storage project.
But what we learned very quickly
was that there's not a lot
of carbon in a diamond actually,
maybe four grams in a one carat stone.
But when we looked at the
diamond mining industry
we found that to make
that same one carat stone
requires the digging
of 1,100 tons of rock,
and the exposure of 30 tons of toxic metal
to the environment,
the consumption of 5,000 liters of water,
and the production of half
a ton of greenhouse gas.
So De Beers have made famous this slogan,
"diamonds are forever".
What they don't tell
you is that the impacts
of diamond mining are forever.
So the holes in the big
diamond mines in Russia
for example, are so big,
you can see them from orbit.
And so the avoided carbon
that we are achieving
through making diamonds
from the sky is way bigger
than the carbon that we're
actually pulling from the sky
and locking up.
And what we make are diamonds.
They're chemically, molecularly
identical to diamonds
that are dug out of the earth.
Lab-grown diamonds as a thing
have been around for decades
but they were small,
and they were used for
industrial diamonds.
Gem type diamonds have
begun to be a major industry
in more or less the last 10 years.
The knowledge that they
exist is becoming greater
but people still have confusion
because there have been
for a long, long time, imitation diamonds,
cubic zirconia, things
that look like diamonds
but are not diamonds.
A lab-grown diamond,
it's not an imitation.
It's not like vegan meat or something,
it is the same thing
made in a different way.
So the magic starts where
we first pull carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere with a
machine from Switzerland.
We then split rain water
into hydrogen and oxygen
and we feed a combination of
hydrogen and carbon dioxide
to our bugs.
These are ancient bacteria
that take these two ingredients
and stitch them together into methane,
and then we feed the methane
along with some other gases
into our diamond ovens.
So in our diamond oven, we
might lay out 16 diamond seeds
in a square pattern.
And they live of in this ball of plasma
while we feed it with gas.
It runs at about a 1,000
degrees centigrade,
so it's very hot.
But within this plasma
ball, we can turn our gases
into a crystalline
structure that is a diamond.
And at the end of two weeks,
we pull out a square like this.
It's like a window with
a, with a black edge.
And we chop this block up
into 16 individual stones
with our laser.
And then we trim each one of those
to remove the black growth
from around the edges
and then we have what we call roughs -
little squares or cubes of material
that looks a little translucent.
And we send it away and
it gets cut and polished
into the shape that we all
traditionally associate
with a diamond.
And is this the, the biggest
one that you've done?
Yes, the biggest, yeah.
And any given batch will come
out with a different color
or clarity, but we are achieving quality
in the top 1% of all
diamonds, we know this,
we send them away for assessment
in the same way that diamonds
ripped out of the Earth
are sent for assessment.
And we get back the same basic metrics.
Although many sort of laboratory do work
with renewable energy, the
source of the original elements
often have to be taken
from existing minerals.
And I think the excitement
with what Skydiamond is doing
is that it actually takes
something that we don't want,
something that is of waste,
and turn that into
something that is treasured.
At retail mined diamonds,
traditional diamonds,
cost two or three times more
than lab grown diamonds.
And I think it's kind of an
old fashioned idea that luxury
requires the most expensive materials.
You can also use more unique designs.
You can use more sort of ingenuity,
many potential sources of value
can make something luxurious.
I think for a younger generation,
the idea that you can have
this scientific breakthrough
to create this special stone
has a kind of romance to it
just as the old "diamond
is forever" slogan
had a different kind of romance.
When working with recycled gold,
you can purchase pellets of gold
that actually come from different sources,
whether it's from tech industries,
extracted from discarded electronics
like computer chips and mobile phones
and also from repurposing
sort of antique jewelry.
So all of this sort of metal
is then remelted together,
and refined into the pellets
that we are using today.
The process of creating this piece
involves first a wax
model of a blade of grass,
so like carving of a miniature sculpture.
From the wax model,
it is then lost-wax casted into gold -
one of the oldest techniques
within fine jewelry.
So how it works is by
setting that wax piece
inside a plaster cast,
and then melting gold pellets,
and pouring the metal
into the plaster cast.
It will then fill the
void where the wax was.
And so you lose the piece of wax
hence the term lost-wax casting.
And once the metal has cooled down,
when you open up your cast,
you will get the piece
that resembles exactly your original wax
but in solid gold.
And from that, you will then start working
on finishing the piece
by filing and assembling.
And within the gold piece,
we will then work on the
setting of each gemstone.
A piece of jewelry finally
sort of come to live
in those final stages of polishing it,
because that's when you
see the transformation
of a piece that is maybe
quite dirty and quite gritty,
and that final polish gives it that shine.
The fine jewelry industry has
always been about prestige.
Whether it's showing off your wealth,
or showing off your power,
what conveys prestige changes over time.
And if that includes being concerned
about the materials that things are made,
not just that they'd be expensive or rare,
but that they'd be ethically sourced,
you're going to have to take
that into consideration.
And that opens the way
for lab-grown gems among other things.
To doubters, I would say
come back in 20 years.
Come back in 20 years
and see where we are.
I suspect that we will
no longer even be talking
about this distinction.
There will just be diamonds.
Lady Gaga wore a pair
of our feather earrings
with laboratory grown Tourmaline.
And that was, for me,
the first time sort of seeing
it out on the red carpet.
It always blows my mind when a celebrity
wears one of our pieces.
I think in the beginning,
people choose it predominantly
for the design and for its aesthetics.
But when they find out more
about the sustainability,
and the ethical sort of
ethos behind what we do
and the reasoning and why
we use certain materials,
they become much more supportive.
The other pair of the broach
features Tahitian pearls
with anodized aluminum.
So pearls used to be
the most precious gems,
the gems that represented
wealth, that represented power.
You see a lot of them in Renaissance art
showing how rich the
person wearing them is,
and the reason the pearls were so valuable
is that they are extremely rare in nature.
But in the a late 19th century
someone figured out that
you could culture pearls,
so that you could have a
reliable supply of pearls.
It became affordable
because of this
technological breakthrough.
But if you owned an old string of pearls
that was worth the price
of a building in Manhattan,
which is a real example,
suddenly that string of
pearls was worth a lot less.
And that is the kind of dynamic
that lab-grown diamonds could present
for the diamond industry.
For this particular piece,
I've chosen to use pearls
from Kamoka Pearls.
I'm always fascinated
by the incredible colors
they are able to achieve
where you get these sort
of pistachio hues to
golden, to silvery gray,
to midnight sort of blue.
I came across Kamoka Pearls
around two, three years ago.
What really drew me to them
was the way they farm their
pearls is a perfect example
of how people can work
with nature in harmony
to actually improve the
environment around them.
So traditionally, when it
comes to pearl farming,
water jets are used to clean the oysters
and by using water jets,
it changes the current
surrounding the oysters,
it can damage the coral reefs
and change the pH level of the water,
and actually disrupts
the whole ecosystems.
Kamoka Pearls utilizes exotic
fishes to clean their oysters.
Not only have they been able to regenerate
the reef surrounding their island,
they've also been able to
regenerate some endangered species
in the ecosystems, which is phenomenal.
Making jewelry is a messy process,
and I always say it is like beauty
emerges from organized chaos.
The process to make this piece
involves hand shaping aluminum metal,
piercing it out of the
sheet using a piercing saw,
and it's very much
guided by subtle changes
of directions to pierce the
piece out into the form,
and then molding it into blade of grass.
Chasing is setting a
piece of some sheet metal
that is essentially flat
into a platform where you shape the metal
by knocking and tapping on the hammer.
So every vein and every grain
has been worked on
individually and organically.
Aluminum is so much lighter than gold
or platinum, or silver.
So I'm able to work with
much sort of bolder geometry.
And at the same time, it is about creating
a new color palette that mimics nature,
because aluminum can be colored
in a myriad of different ways
compared to traditional precious metals.
You run an electric current into a bath
where the metal is then submerged into
sort of different tanks and beakers
that allows the color to be
imbued into the aluminum.
I've chosen a specific type of pearl
that reflects the colors in the leaves.
And to set the pearl into aluminum,
we then create a cup
with a pin in the center,
which is known as the setting.
The pearl is then drilled,
and then to secure in place,
we use a resin.
I see this pair of broaches
being equally shared
between sort of partners
and family members.
Equally worn by men and
women at the same time.
They are inspired by the same elements,
presented in a different language,
yet they complement each
other in the same way.
I think the future of fine jewelry
really is about sustainable and ethical
and mindful operations in every sense.
And it's being able to learn from the past
to offer different
perspective in the present,
always in mind for a better future.
I suppose this is one of my
favorite quotes by Maya Angelou,
"Do the best you can
until you know better.
And when you know better, do better."